[Music]
in short snatch news I just thought
about a sock [ __ ] submitted by
Elizabeth loves baby tiger three people
stole a shark from a state aquarium and
briefly got away with it not about
felicity
well who stole the People v people would
you steal a shark please don't let it be
Asians that wanna cook it knows Asians
want to take a picture with it oh I know
this took place in San Antonio I thank
God it might be Mexican oh sorry I do
[ __ ] like this this doesn't make sense
to us
estra uh my friend was a notorious thief
of pets and he taught me how to steal
frog
pitbulls is what we're good for uh what
else do we wait stealing pit bulls yeah
yeah dude but you're going to like oh
there's puppies pit bulls bikes
automobiles personal valuables all right
well bang equipment diamonds your
expensive art jewelry bank heist the
crown jewels yet Queens you know all
that bank heist this time mm-hmm Casey
Asian they just smuggle people and drug
mule people property okay ideas and
hearts I don't know about the hearts we
see a really nice suit sometimes very
expensive suits you go in and you try on
the suit and then you walk out the door
and then you say tiptip cheerio as you
leave and then and you're out of there
that sometimes math we still not to
sometimes the people nowhere and I wish
oh you guys surveillance footage of when
these three people stole a shark it was
one of those you know like those petting
aquarium yeah yeah like a small
competitive short yeah we can put them
up oh that's what that kind of heading
required all right so everything takes
place right over here keep your eyes on
this side I wonder if the starfish ever
get like tired of being fondled all
they or they enjoy it Oh have you enjoy
it I don't know Letty a starfish oh yeah
cuz I see the kids they [ __ ] crazy
every time remember when we were at the
[ __ ] Natural History Museum or
whatever it was by USC man there was a
bunch of school kids going [ __ ] crazy
on that [ __ ] they're just like give me
my turn oh yeah and I was like damn
you're [ __ ] that guy up there like
pulling on it and [ __ ] I was like
cartoons it was like it was stretchy -
oh look a flex arms Tom but he's a
[ __ ] living starfish yep and it was
like a [ __ ] stingray like holy [ __ ]
trying to [ __ ] da Japan's that were
going in and [ __ ] like Finding Nemo and
[ __ ] there's nowhere to run they're on
every end they just keep going in
circles
oh [ __ ] looking handsome should try to
juke out the fingers the best boxes Nora
and I just pick up a starfish and I
started [ __ ] [ __ ] with their
little stickies do let you pick it up
they're not what I suppose do just
because they were [ __ ] crowding my
space alright here we go
so over here okay so this woman looking
at there's a there's a stroller right
here this man just picked up oh the
shark yes with their own net what do
they think to do he's walking to a back
room nobody noticed no you know it's
crazy lunch oh he's he's coming back
he's putting the shark into the stroller
and then right over here this woman here
she works in the aquarium she kind of
noticed this what the hell is going on
but she wasn't doing anything she's like
hey this looks kind of weird yeah it's
just kind of like what but nothing
happens maybe she didn't register yeah I
don't think she went because there's no
way people are gonna be like oh yeah
somebody's just putting a shark in a
baby carriage yeah so then they just
took off in the stroller and what they
burn is suffocating an air they
suffocate when out of water
so they got they went to this back room
they emptied out a bucket of bleach
cleaning solution that's used for
sterilizing - oh God
they dumped it into the filtration
where they could have killed hundreds of
animals but luckily the staff found out
somehow and they ended up saving these
animals so the part Pete and the
clarinha balanced it up so then you know
the science of it yeah thank you to do
this with their hot tub at home Oh
balances the pH exactly bro let's do
something that or nothing because
there's a little tester sticks and he's
a colon no wonder that [ __ ] was green
the last time we took a [ __ ] dip in
that boat okay we're at aunt's house
memory dance pool yeah yeah no wonder
was salty all right so then they use
that bucket to have water in it like
they put water in it and then they put
the shark into that bucket they took
that bucket into the stroller how small
is this Charlie a little baby shark yeah
her name is Miss Helen they have a name
damn yeah a 16 inch long horn shark why
would people steal the short I don't
understand why do they have like a water
tank at home sick looking myself so they
are saying that yeah these people are
horrible because they took this shark
but at least they knew what they were
doing cuz when Officer so they did catch
the license plate from surveillance so
they kept him alive they did have like a
makeshift like their own little aquarium
with all kinds of different exotic
fishes and then they found or they asked
this man if they had proof he had proof
that he purchased that shark so then he
showed them a forged receipt of that
same type of shark he even made a
receipt that's smart but then later on
he finally confessed that he did steal
it because obviously there was
surveillance footage how could he deny
that so they were chasing this shark out
for an hour
can you for an hour not only that but a
month earlier one of the guys cuz those
two guys and a woman that was involved
in here one of the guys they he showed
up to the aquarium and pretended to be
part of the facility's salt supplier
company and so he got in all Ashley's
tour of my
in the back of it but so they did this
all to keep a pet like this wasn't to
sell or anything
apparently this dude had a shark a
similar shark that had died and so he
that even gets to tell me that this
shark is worth like a hundred fifty
bucks that's all I need Melvin okay okay
okay dude this is all a this is what
happened all right
so this is the whole time I thought they
were expert shark thieves and then they
sold it in the black market but this is
what happened all right
so this guy he had his shark he raises
since it was like a [ __ ] little teeny
pot right and then his name is Jerry
he loves his shark right and everybody
it's like the community shark now
everybody comes over tonight hey you
guys you guys CJ yeah and it's like
their [ __ ] mascot
Jerry dies one day they go to the
aquarium to kind of like get some
closure and then he goes oh my god that
shot looks just like Jerry right two
years later they're like I can't get
that chunk out of my way man I need to
have that short so all of his friends
were like I'm gonna steal the
Declaration of Independence and then
they planned this heist they go down
they [ __ ] scope the place out
they [ __ ] steal the shark he's happy
as [ __ ] but damn bait cata now yes sir
nice to give the shark back that's a
[ __ ] movie right there that's a it's a
it's a movie yeah
[Laughter]
shock love yeah how was that pitch [ __ ]
low pitch it's funny when he's not
thinking pictures pretty well yeah I
came from the heart
that's why how did you pitch me nine
movies that weren't movies but you just
pitch me that and I was like that's a
movie I think cuz I don't know you can
have it in you know all along yeah I had
it in me
I'm proud of you just thinking it was
based off a real life story that's why
this one touched me in the [ __ ] soul
dads that's why that's like ball sacks
but like heart no but you know it's
crazy oh so they could have killed her
because they removed her from her 76
degree water and placed her in a
52-degree water which she
not Hildur yeah but luckily she she held
on now she's recovering doggins of
sharks know how to survive as warm yes
you less than a year old
oh how long is that in shark ears though
you know I mean like we think baby they
might be a grandma you home do they last
no no did you even research this article
I didn't I'm sorry
shark age calm no type it in see how old
you are
is it is it rare do they actually have
horns are they a racer 2,000 bucks
that sounds cheapest [ __ ] you shark a
hundred and fifty grand like it so it's
like a [ __ ] famous box or [ __ ] 50
grand or something I always get bummed
when they call some in a shark and it's
not like a big ass shark yeah like these
little guys wouldn't be the shark I
don't want to I don't like that we cost
some sharks off of Santa Monica Pier
they were like this big
that's what I mean yeah and then it
actually survived for a couple months so
we got in a fish tank yeah well it
wasn't fresh water like we had to buy
the the saltwater because it was sick
looking but there was like two of them
just [ __ ] swimming around in my
friends backyard we had a big [ __ ]
tank we'll just load it up with
saltwater and we just kept beating a
shrimp and all kinds of [ __ ] and stayed
alive yeah until I forgot what happened
okay and they live about 12 years I seen
that fool everyone I was a kid and
they're like we're going to aquarium you
get to get it to see sharks I was like
[ __ ] yeah good to see a [ __ ] shark
he's gonna have a mouth like like so big
and then I'm at the agreement it's [ __ ]
like that what's the point
just don't call it a shark quick fix
them I know like when you think of your
parents pop top not a petting zoo but
like a pet tank or like a feeler tank or
whatever you call those and then you
think oh you get to [ __ ] pass sharks
you're thinking of great whites yeah I'm
thinking exactly you thinking of like
look at they can eat you one bite yeah I
didn't so there's a pool and you're a
little kid you just [ __ ] get the
touch I'm like this and [ __ ]
did you get home on your life I've
touched this job exactly he was like
this big yeah yeah I love that [ __ ] yeah
because when you're kidding all you
wanna do is bang about stuff so yep I
bragged about my dad - uh knowing magic
I like was telling everyone my dad know
how to do magic I told one kid that his
dad sucks a drawing my dad's way better
drawing I might had any of our you can
pay me tell my dad draw anything you
probably heard his feelings like a
[ __ ]
because his dad was like a cartoonist
yeah and I was like your dad stopped to
dry and I was like my dad's way better
cuz I just had to win
[Music]
[Music]